how do you think people are going to
take to it do you think it's going to be
i mean it also depends because if people
attack it like they're already attacking
it it's going to bring more attention to
it it's going to bring more followers to
it but it's going to be interesting if
they're going to launch like
infrastructure attacks on if trump is on
it
the media will be forced to be on it
these journalists will have no choice
yeah because trump will be posting and
they have to cover it i forgot about the
trump reply guys
they want their jobs back
yeah jeff he was like i remember he
tweeted something about almost quitting
and then he's like i gotta figure
something out because i don't have
anything other than trump my identity is
defined by there is entire careers built
off replying to trump tweets
there's entire books there's books being
sold of all of his tweets right now that
are sold out
so again
the guy was uh interesting the guy was
funny the guy
knew how to get attention and um
you know i i think i think a lot of his
trolling a lot of his comments are
desperately needed in the kind of
sanitized digital world that we're
living in i know a guy
he used to be a regular journalist
normal dude
little regular millennial guy and then
one day he responded to trump and he
said something dumb made no sense added
to the conversation but then he got
followers
and then he kept doing it and then i was
talking to him and i was like like what
are you what are you doing like you know
you used to cover serious topics and
he's like oh i'm just you know
responding to trump
and then after like a couple of years he
had destroyed his career completely
he
was unable to my understanding get
serious journalistic work started
working for activists
and then when trump left
it's all over
imagine destroying your life as a
serious reporter because you found out
you're getting followers by calling
trump a poo poo head wow what a life
what a life that's funny those type of
people too those are the same people who
remember remember when they would say
that trump was they were worried about
if he was unfit for office right now
look at who we have the guy's probably
down the street getting spoon fed in a
rocking chair right now watching john
with the blanket on his back yeah
remember when he said that he what did
he call that guy the uh a dog-faced pony
liar tony soldier pony soldier what is
that from an old western no it's not
true it's not true so
at first the media was like it's
actually an old line from a movie and
then someone pulled the movie up and
it's like
it's like he took three different movies
and mashed random things together
lion dog faces with ponies consistent to
his brand basically when he speaks have
you guys seen freedom tunes new uh i
like those yeah the rogan one i haven't
seen a new one no the new one is joe
biden's greatest hits oh i got to watch
and it's like
you're not shopping at a pressure coming
down on me and i'm like oh sheamus so
good out of the park out of the park i
do this thing with biden now whereas
like i try to i want to make it a whole
presidential term without actually
listening to what the president has to
say so i try not to get through like one
when he shows up on my feet i try to cut
it off before the end of his sentence
which is easy to do because he doesn't
actually form sentences so it's easy to
do that but um i just feel like it's a
waste of time to listen what he's saying
he's reading from a teleprompter he
doesn't believe in what he's saying he
has people behind him tell him what to
do
let me if he can read the teleprompter
let me point out the differences we have
right here now i can't speak for every
person on the right there's a lot of
people who reply to biden and kamala and
it's like the weirdest thing it's i find
it's the most annoying thing to me
honestly i don't care from the left or
the right i'll see a tweet from like
kamala harris i'll click it and then
i'll see a bunch of verified like
libertarian moderate or right-wing
people just saying stuff like you're so
dumb like you're wrong about i'm like
why are you playing reply guy to biden
it's just so strong why i even
acknowledge it why even acknowledge him
into your life it's like
demi lovato thing like why waste your
time even writing that in but i will say
this
when trump would say something people
would just call him stupid they'd say
you're evil you're racist you're a bigot
you're dumb
and now you know now they're like wait
what'd you say what
yeah bite in our like this policy is
incorrect and you know you're failing
but there's a lot of the same stuff
there's a lot of the same reply guy
stuff but i will say the big difference
is that
there's no real career reply guys for
biden you're not going to gain followers
by replying to biden like you could
reply to trump right and so this bread a
class of people who made a living my
favorite is when like these these people
like jeff what's his face i want to say
his name
anyway
people like him
who would be like if you like my insult
of trump please here's my paypal link
and give me money that's so cool here's
my here's my patreon wow who are these
people you know people like that i knew
one guy ugh yeah he's his kid career's
over he must be fun at parties yeah you
know what the reality is normal dude
these are normal people and then i got
to tell you when you have like
i i i can't imagine having this
mentality but this guy he's got like a
thousand followers which is like you
know bottom rung and then all of a
sudden he has two thousand followers all
because he trump he called trump a dumb
ass or something yeah and then after a
week he's like i'm gaining tons of
followers so what they do is they pull
up trump's twitter and they would just
refresh and then as soon as it would
come in they'd immediately be like oh i
got to be the first person what a sad
existence oh terrible they set up
notifications and we have to understand
big tech social media rewarded these
people they were able to get all the
followers all the replies all the likes
they saw the conflict social media said
ooh conflict let's put this up on the
front page let's put this up so everyone
sees it and they got their response they
loved donald trump they loved every
aspect of him even though they hated him
even though they said he was they
scorned him even though they cursed him
out whenever they could even though they
attacked them disingenuously whenever
they could at the end of the day the big
tech social media companies and and also
let's not forget uh the mainstream media
loved him because he
revitalized their entire careers that
were already going downhill they're
going downhill right now because we have
a president that barely even tweets but
barely even says anything coherently
that they can't even respond to yeah
it's sad they love the divide too which
is kind of the saddest thing that's why
i feel like what we need to do because
we're always at odds it's the left
versus the right you turn on cnn they're
pointing fingers at the right you turn
on fox news they're pointing fingers at
the left why don't we just take the
north east the south the mid the middle
america and the west coast and just form
our own countries with our own
governments and our own presidents and
then you go where you fit into and then
you leave everyone the hell alone
because it's like what are we going to
do it's a constant tug-of-war battle
going on you get a democrat in office
and then you get a republican undo
with the previous president if we're
lucky
yeah yeah so you know so i pulled up
someone someone commented in super chat
it's truthsocial.com you can join the
waiting list so people have found ways
to effectively gain access to the site
i'm going to tell you this right now
the first people to sign up for that
waiting list reply guys
yep trump's
what's the opposite of a sycophant
someone who walks around complaining
about your farts
files stalkers
and you know what i'm willing to bet
they cried
i'm willing to bet they were sitting
there when they heard this announcement
they just like started crying like
they matter
please trump please let me on your
platform and these are the same people
that called for him to get banned and
now they're they're getting wow that's
what i was saying when when they were
talking about banning trump i was like
it'd be really bad for them because they
need trump to be their boogeyman and it
has been it absolutely has been because
now they're the power in charge they're
the ones that everyone's looking at like
okay you got everything you needed you
got rid of the bad boogie man now show
us what you got and what you got is an
absolute utter crap storm on huge epic
proportions of financial calamities
facts mandates more people getting sick
more people dying from the sickness than
they did under donald trump which they
blamed for every single person that
passed away now more people are dying
and then biden oh yeah he's he's not
default we should make an account on
twitter called like trump scarecrow or
whatever
and it's just like it's a fake trump
account so that the reply guys have
somewhere to be and to like you know
it's like their safe space yeah yeah so
it's you know it brings them back to the
good old times glory days when they were
getting followers
and and some kind of attention but it's
it's it's mainly an attention game here
and that's the weird part because
they've been incentivized to know the
dirtier the nastier the the more
disgusting they are the more people look
at them and there's a certain point to
that where people are like oh you're
really ugly but there's there's there's
the initial part like oh well there's a
car wreck over there let's let's at
least look make sure whatever's going on
there there's this kind of initial first
look so i think we reached that point
where it's just utter disgust and people
realize how nasty it is and and and
algorithm feeds it to people and
i think a lot of people eventually not
yet i don't think we're there yet but i
think eventually are going to be utterly
disgusted with what the timeline
provides for them
did you find mastodon in the source in
the inspect the code on the page no i
just said inspect but apparently it's in
there yeah it says mastodon and it's
definitely says it's proprietary in the
terms of service
in the terms of service here that's the
link there yeah but it's not live yet it
could be a placeholder well it's right
we don't know when the front page is
live and yeah that's mastered on code
and they're uh saying it's proprietary
then they're violent and all source code
well it's just wrong like what you need
to understand illegal no it isn't what
ian
if i said ian i own your coat is that
illegal
well if you're wearing it and walking
around town with it and i didn't give
you permission yeah
what do you mean just a copy it's not
the real thing right if if source code
says you cannot copy this without like
creative copy wait a minute i thought
you're the open the source guy for big
social networks yeah let's talk about it
a social network functioning in the
comments but not for the people
it hasn't it's not part of the commons
yet if it becomes so ubiquitous that no
no ian you're wrong he didn't steal
anything it's a copy of it if he copied
gpl
code but you said copying isn't isn't
theft
it's not theft okay so what's the
problem he's violating the sort the
license no it's a copy
because it's the gpl license you can't
copy gpl license without crediting the
the original source code
ins a guy who came out and said piracy
isn't theft because it's just a copy and
you're not taking the real thing and now
he's made that trump copied it yeah
digital copying is not the same thing as
stealing someone's original
what huh
ian you can't have both positions it
makes no sense yeah i'm so you're saying
he's pirating the software is that what
you're saying sure let's say that's not
legal tim
okay
what we'll see i mean if it's are you
are you encouraging people to take gpl
code and make it private we don't know
if that's the case oh exactly we don't
know what exactly is going on and you
don't know uh as to what on the site
might be proprietary but you said it was
illegal and the point i'm making is that
like dude if i tell people that i own
your glasses i didn't commit a crime by
doing it yeah but if you're walking
around displaying that as your own then
you are he's not the site's not live
it's truth social.com is live right now
oh it isn't i just go i'm on it yeah
you're not you pulled it up didn't you
you you're not you know the login part
might not be my public yep oh the
mastodon part isn't actually truth
social.com the mastodon part isn't
actually there and you didn't find it in
the inspect
because it's not here i thought you just
said it was they they got to you no i
said
yes but what i meant was people who
broke in searched the source code of the
social platform and found that mastodon
was listed on the actual site that's
live it doesn't say it as far as i know
but regardless regardless i know trump
is it probably doing something wrong i'm
gonna wait until it goes live before i
start joining in on the on the
mainstream media the vomitorium
orange man bad narrative when you say go
live when when the front page is live
the site has gone live even if you can't
get in and log in yet the site is still
live
you're just trying you try so hard to
like change
a social network i know what it means
you're you're fighting an allegation
made by the mainstream media against
donald trump when when the right
position in my opinion should be let's
just wait
yeah i think you're both right i think
yeah i'm not i'm not going to push the
issue here maybe he will let's just wait
and find out i think that's i just don't
understand why ian's mad about this i
don't understand it's important to me
that if you use free software code that
you uphold the license
well maybe maybe they have a license how
do you know if they don't have a license
in their terms they say it's proprietary
so maybe they have a license yeah but
they will be a proprietary license
that's not gps or maybe they have maybe
they have a different agreement with
masternode we don't know yet
guys said he's gonna sue private
property
like i don't know then you thought wrong
but you had a huge argument about ip you
said copying isn't illegal it should be
allowed well i don't know if i didn't
say copying isn't illegal i said copying
and stealing are different you said
copying is okay it's not theft because
it's not the real i didn't say it's okay
either i said it's not stealing it's
different than stealing so piracy in the
old days was if a pirate would go to
your ship and take your stuff and you
don't have it anymore nowadays they make
a copy of it and they call it piracy but
it's different than that old school i
write a song and then someone copies it
and then shares it with a billion people
is that wrong
you could make that argument yeah do you
think it is wrong i mean
right and wrong aren't the words i would
use for it but it's definitely not the
way the system's built to be from well
that's the opposite of what you said you
know a couple weeks ago ian they're
really coming down and you know i got a
message from an anonymous source
on my instagram that said to tell ian to
shut up and i have a feeling that it was
tim that sent me that to be honest
no
it's hey i'm making bold claims and they
need to have horses i'm defending you i
don't agree right
what i'm talking about is extremely it's
it's extremely jarring to the system so
we need people to punch holes in the
things i'm saying because i need to make
sure that what i'm saying is bulletproof
if i'm going to go forward with it
donald trump should not take open source
code and then lock it up and then
develop on top of it while restricting
access to it it's okay with open source
but not with free software like gpl it's
not open source code that's free
software code oh right so he's taking
freeware and then turning it into not
freeware free software licensing code
freeware is like uh diablo one yeah you
can go take for free
you